next debate that we looked at Marjorie
Taylor green versus Challenger Marcus
flowers this one is like nothing I have
ever ever seen first and foremost
Marjorie Taylor green accuses one of the
journalists on the panel of being a
Democrat activist so-called because of a
question he asked take a look at this
and we need to what can you tell me give
me an example no you do this every time
we have a debate where you I ask a
question that's obvious and you're like
what you mean you were kicked off with
your committees for saying things were
controversial you've apologized for
controversial statements right those
types of things what is your process for
fact checking and vetting the things
that you say in public I the the things
I say in public are the truth and that's
why they're so offensive to Democrat
activists in the media just like you
notice how that's not an answer that's
not well here's how I fact check no it's
you're a Democrat activist for even
asking that and you're asking me a
blanket question with no example I stand
by the things that I say I stand by
saying she stands by It Whatever It Is
she stands by it and of course she said
some horrible things Marjorie Taylor
green flips out when her opponent Marcus
flowers accuses her of fomenting the
sentiment that led to January 6 by
pushing election big live stuff and then
he tries to pin her down as to whether
Joe Biden won she refuses to answer she
says only that Joe Biden is the
president this is really embarrassing to
almost to a person
has said Marjorie Taylor green is not
who they want representing them
so yes this campaign is about Marcus
flowers
not not MTG thank you Josh I'd need a
rebuttal to that uh you cannot accuse me
of insurrection I was a victim of the
January 6 Riot just as much as any other
member of Congress that was the third
day I had on the job I had nothing to do
with what happened there that day and I
will not have you accuse me of that that
is wrong of you to do you're lying about
me and you will not defame my character
in that manner did Joe Biden win the
election congresswoman Greene Joe Biden
is the president of the United States
understand that that's how they avoid it
they say he is the president but they
won't say he won absolutely but you
pushed a big lie that said he did not
win the election
I drove those people to the Capitol on
January 6.
we're going to move on Joshua and my
question
my husband has proof that's another one
of the lies she's been telling
um Marcus flowers is really good and
sadly I don't think he stands a chance
from the little polling I've seen
Marjorie Taylor green was asked what's
the accomplishment you're most proud of
and she basically says Democrats haven't
let me do anything but I got some grants
and your question from Audrey Taylor
green
aye Ms Green since taking office on
January 3rd 2021 what is the one
specific accomplishment solely on behalf
of the 14th congressional district that
is most important to you well I tell you
what it's been hard to pass any bills in
a democrat-controlled Nancy
pelosi-controlled House of
representation real real personal
responsibility I couldn't do anything
because of the Democrats that it is I I
I a senate that is controlled by one
vote with Kamala Harris as Kamala the
Democrat vice president and a white
house that is controlled by by democrats
Joe Biden now what we've done to
accomplish things for Northwest Georgia
is I'm proud to be able to bring in
money via grants to help our local
sheriff's department and help local
businesses there we've also worked very
hard with the flooding that happened
over in Somerville Somerville and so
we've worked hand in hand with officials
there and look forward to helping them
more as damages and amounts of money
come out so I'm very excited to to vote
and to introduce bills that uphold the
conservative traditional traditional
values of the people in my district even
her grin seems to suggest she knows this
is BS can you to do that all right Josh
you get the final question did you have
a rebuttal yeah I didn't hear an answer
there ladies and gentlemen
representative green said she's passed
all these bills and brought money into
our district well you haven't you know
no I voted
okay anyway so just a complete and total
disaster
um one more segment here Marcus flowers
actually a couple this was really
interesting Marcus flowers asked
Marjorie Taylor green why does she seem
to care more about the insurrectionists
than people in her district and she did
not like that you know you spent your
time in Congress these last couple of
years
providing Aid and comfort to the January
6th insurrectionists my question for you
is why do you care more about those
criminals in jail
than you do about the people of our
district you want to know something I
care about about stopping the two-tier
justice system that is happening right
now in America which she thinks is
trumpists and everyone else but the real
two-tier justice system is the
privileged and Elite and everybody else
I was a victim of the January 6 Riot and
I've said it over and over again I'm
completely against what happened on
January 6 but I will not Stand By and
Watch Merritt Garland turn the
Department of Justice into a political
weapon and the FBI sending it after
parents that are addressing their school
boards people that walked in the Capitol
and have been held in jail for nearly
two years while antifa and BLM riots
rioters Go free are never held
accountable now of course that's not
true and the hilarity of a republican
suddenly caring about pre-trial
detention is really really quaint last
clip she does pull out the Q Anon stuff
pedophilia child abuse Etc at party the
Democrat Party is the party of child
abuse piece it's the party that
represents grooming children and
sexualizing them in school teaching
anti-white racism in the terms of CRT
education and genital mutilation of kids
kids that can't even get a driver's
license can't get a tattoo and cannot
vote how do you stand there and
represent the Democrat Party as a father
and do you believe in genital mutilation
of children under the age of 18 and and
these puberty blockers that have severe
Health consequence so a really buzzword
Q Anon Bingo there for Marjorie Taylor
green she sadly will probably win and
that says more about the country than it
does about Marcus flowers who is an
excellent candidate we'll take a quick
break and then look at the Ron Johnson
Mandela Barnes interview uh right after
this
one of our sponsors is paired the app
for couples every day paired gives you
and your partner questions quizzes games
to have fun to stay connected to deepen
your conversations and get to know each
other better what's great about it is
you don't even have to be in the same
room especially with the baby right now
my girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent go to paired.com Pacman to
download the app and get a seven day
free trial the link is down below